I have a friend who would like to know what is feeding his cancer, but he is not interested in
ulcerative medicine. Is there a test he could do to ask his oncologist? No, there isn't.
There's some things that a person could do. And I think I write about it in my book about,
I mean, you know, just do trial and error things. I mean, if you're on a, let's say a ketogenic type
diet or, you know, a ketogenic like diet, and, you know, your successful tests are showing,
you know, a curve upwards to be your cancer is getting worse. Well, then switch your diet,
you know, do an opposite diet, do a juicing diet or something like that. So, you have to cut
an experiment with that then and see, you know, what makes you feel best and what makes the,
you know, the tumor change. Now, some people that have a tumor that is visual or visual or palpable,
it's easier to know, hey, you know, when I eat this, it seems like when I've been comments from,
from many of you, you know, with a breast tumor, when I eat such and such, you know, it feels like my
tumor actually gets bigger and it feels irritated. So, I stay away from that. When I stick to this diet,
it, I just feel better and it seems like my tumor is going in the right direction. That's,
that's a fair way to do that. Now, if you have a cancer in your test cell tract and you have no way
of palpating or knowing whether it's getting better or worse, then it makes it more difficult
until you're dependent upon tests, but you can certainly, you know, run the tumor marker test
for something like that to monitor progress.